devrait ouvrir un compte en fiducie pour chaque nouveau-né
d'un montant pouvant atteindre jusqu'à 60 000 dollars,
en fonction de la situation financière familiale à sa naissance.
Je parle de dotation.
Un capital d'amorçage personnel, une fiducie publique pour bébé,
ce que mon collègue de l'université de Duke, William Darity, et moi
appelons des « baby bonds »,
un terme inventé par un historien de l'Université de Columbia,
Manning Marable.
La raison pour laquelle nous devons créer ces fiducies est simple.
La richesse est un indicateur essentiel de la sécurité économique et du bien-être.
Elle fournit un pouvoir financier et une sécurité économique
afin de prendre des risques et de se protéger en cas d'échec.
Sans capital, les inégalités persistent.
On parle de choix et de liberté pour décrire les avantages du marché
mais c'est la richesse qui nous offre le choix, la liberté et des options.
Les familles les plus riches peuvent financer une grande école indépendante
et des études à l'université,
accéder à des capitaux pour créer une entreprise,
financer des interventions médicales coûteuses,
habiter dans des quartiers aux infrastructures développées,
exercer une influence politique à travers le financement d'une campagne,
s'offrir les services d'un conseiller juridique
si elles doivent faire face aux coûts élevés du système de justice pénale,
faire un legs,
et/ou faire face aux difficultés financières suite à des crises.
Lorsqu'il s'agit de sécurité économique,
tout repose sur la richesse.
Je vais construire mon discours au regard du contexte américain
mais il peut s'appliquer à n'importe quel pays
faisant face à des inégalités croissantes.
Aux États-Unis, les 10 % des foyers les plus aisés
détiennent environ 80 % de la richesse nationale,
tandis que les 60 % des foyers les moins aisés n'en détiennent que 1 %.
Lorsqu'il s'agit de richesse,
l'ethnie devient un indicateur plus important que la classe sociale.
Les Noirs et les Latinos représentent 30 %
de la population américaine,
mais ne détiennent qu'environ 7 % de la richesse nationale.
Un sondage datant de 2016 sur les crédits à la consommation
montre qu'une famille noire type possède un capital de 17 000 dollars,
comprenant la valeur nette du patrimoine,
tandis que celui d'une famille blanche s'élève à 170 000 dollars.
Cela démontre un écart de richesse significatif selon l'ethnie.
Là où un foyer noir type possède 10 cents, un foyer blanc possède un dollar.
Indépendamment de l'ethnie,
le marché lui-même ne permet pas de résoudre ces inégalités.
Même en temps de croissance économique, les inégalités s'accroissent.
Ces 45 dernières années,
les disparités de richesse n'ont cessé d'augmenter
et les avantages économiques découlant de la productivité croissante américaine
n'ont profité qu'à l'élite ou à la classe moyenne supérieure.
Pourtant, l'encadrement autour de la disparité économique
se concentre sur les mauvais choix
des emprunteurs noirs, latinos et pauvres.
Cet encadrement est injuste.
On met l'accent sur les mauvaises choses.
Il est plus probable qu'une faible situation économique,
et non des mauvaises décisions ou un manque de connaissances,
limite les choix et ne laisse aux gens aucune autre option
que celle de se tourner vers de la finance abusive.
Dans l'absolu, l'éducation n'est pas le remède miracle
contre les grandes disparités dont on hérite,
qui découlent de lois, de politiques et d'accords économiques.
L'éducation n'en reste pas moins importante.
En effet, je suis professeur à l'université.
L'éducation possède des valeurs intrinsèques indéniables
et la responsabilité publique
d'offrir à chacun une éducation de qualité,
de l'école primaire à l'université.
Mais l'éducation n'est pas une panacée.
Au contraire, une famille noire dont le père est diplômé
est généralement moins riche
qu'une famille blanche dont le père a arrêté l'école.
Peut-être surestimons-nous le rôle de l'éducation
au détriment de la compréhension du rôle de la richesse.
Dans le fond, la richesse engendre toujours plus de richesse.
C'est pourquoi on défend les fiducies pour bébé.
Un droit à la naissance offrant un capital à chacun.
Ces comptes en fiducie seraient contrôlés par l'État
et seraient la base d'une vie sûre d'un point de vue économique.
Le concept de droits économiques n'est ni nouveau, ni radical.
En 1944, le président Franklin Roosevelt
a introduit l'idée d'une déclaration des droits de l'économie.
Roosevelt a plaidé en faveur de la sécurité physique,
économique, sociale et morale.
Malheureusement, depuis l'administration Nixon,
l'opinion politique à l'égard de la mobilité sociale
a basculé des mandats offrant la sécurité économique
à une approche néolibérale
selon laquelle le marché est censé être la solution à tous nos problèmes,
qu'ils soient économiques ou autres.
Ainsi, la responsabilité de la mobilité sociale est devenue individuelle.
Il existe cette idée répandue que même si votre niveau de vie est faible,
avec de la persévérance et du travail et grâce aux avantages du marché,
vous pouvez passer de la misère à la richesse.
L'inconvénient, évidemment, c'est que les avantages du marché
sanctionneront probablement ceux qui ne sont pas ingénieux,
ceux qui manquent de motivation ou qui sont simplement fainéants.
En d'autres termes, les pauvres méritants seront justement récompensés.
Ce qui n'est pas pris en compte dans cette idée,
c'est le rôle du pouvoir et du capital
et la manière dont le pouvoir et le capital
peuvent changer les lois et la structure des transactions et des marchés
en premier lieu.
Le pouvoir et le capital se renforcent mutuellement.
Sans l'intervention du gouvernement,
ils provoquent un cycle itératif de stratifications et d'inégalités.
Le financement du capital prévu par les fiducies pour bébé
est destiné à offrir une voie authentique et plus égalitaire
vers la sécurité économique,
indépendamment de la situation financière familiale
dans laquelle on se trouve à la naissance.
Ce concept compléterait les droits économiques aux pensions de vieillesse
et offrirait un programme de sécurité sociale plus complet,
conçu pour permettre le financement du capital de la naissance à la mort.
Nous envisageons l'ouverture d'un compte de 25 000 $ aux nouveau-nés américains
pouvant aller jusqu'à 60 000 dollars
pour les bébés nés dans des familles pauvres.
Les bébés nés dans les familles les plus riches
seraient également inclus dans le contrat social,
mais ils bénéficieraient d'un compte d'environ 500 dollars symboliques.
Les comptes, gérés par le gouvernement,
augmenteraient selon un taux d'intérêt annuel garanti
d'environ 2 % par an afin de limiter le coût de l'inflation.
Ils pourraient être utilisés au moment du passage à l'âge adulte
à des fins d'accroissement d'actifs
tels que le financement d'études sans endettement,
un acompte pour l'achat d'une maison
ou un capital d'amorçage pour créer une entreprise.
Avec environ quatre millions de naissances par an aux États-Unis,
si la dotation moyenne d'une fiducie pour bébé s'élève à 25 000 dollars,
le programme coûterait environ 100 milliards de dollars par an.
Cela représenterait
seulement 2 % des dépenses fédérales actuelles environ,
ce qui serait moins élevé que les plus de 500 milliards de dollars
déjà dépensés par le gouvernement fédéral
sur la valorisation des actifs à travers des crédits d'impôts et des subventions.
Le problème n'est pas le montant de cette allocation,
mais à qui elle est attribuée.
Actuellement, le 1 % des foyers les plus riches,
ceux qui gagnent plus de 100 millions de dollars,
reçoit environ un tiers de cette allocation,
tandis que les 60 % les moins riches n'en reçoivent que 5 %.
Si le budget alloué à la valorisation d'actifs
était réparti de manière plus progressive,
les politiques fédérales pourraient transformer le quotidien des Américains.
C'est un travail en cours.
Il y a évidemment encore de nombreux aspects à régler
mais c'est une proposition politique fondée sur les rôles fonctionnels
de la richesse et de ses avantages
qui nous éloigne de la dégradation de la situation actuelle,
des explications comportementales des inégalités
et nous rapproche de solutions plus structurelles.
Notre politique fiscale actuelle privilégie la richesse déjà existante
plutôt qu'une nouvelle richesse résultant d'un choix.
L'étendue de ces tristes inégalités est aussi bien un problème politique
qu'économique.
Il est temps d'aller au-delà de ces fausses idées
qui imputent les inégalités aux déficits individuels
tout en niant amplement les avantages de la richesse.
Les dispositions portant sur les fiducies pour bébé
pourraient contribuer à la suppression
d'un héritage économique, positif ou négatif, d'une génération à l'autre
et à la mise en place d'une économie plus morale et plus décente
qui facilite la gestion des actifs, la sécurité économique
et la mobilité sociale pour tous les citoyens.
Peu importe leur origine
et leur situation familiale à la naissance.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Darrick.
Cette idée est très intéressante.
Il y a une image autour de celle-ci qui m'inquiète,
c'est qu'actuellement, les enfants bénéficiant d'une fiducie sont mal vus.
Ils sont l'archétype des enfants oisifs,
car l'argent leur retire toute motivation.
Ces fiducies sont différentes.
Comment démontrer aux gens que cette proposition n'aura pas le même effet ?
DH : Si vous savez que vos ressources sont limitées
ou que vous êtes discriminés,
il y a cette idée, vous savez,
qu'investir pour soi ne rapporte pas autant que pour les autres,
donc autant profiter et faire ce que j'aime.
Évidemment, il y a une autre idée,
donc on devrait oublier la précédente,
celle qu'une personne pauvre et victime de discrimination
peut aussi adapter une stratégie pour étoffer son CV.
Ne dit-on pas qu'il faut être deux fois plus compétent que les autres.
On ne se demande par contre jamais à quel prix
ou si des coûts de santé y sont associés.
Je n'ai pas répondu à votre question, mais pour y revenir,
si vous savez que vous allez percevoir une somme d'argent à un moment donné,
cela vous motive à investir en vous-même
afin de mieux utiliser cette fiducie.
CA : Vous donnez aux gens des perspectives de vie
qu'ils n'oseraient imaginer actuellement.
Et ainsi la motivation pour le faire.
Je pourrais en parler des heures avec vous.
Je suis ravi que vous travailliez dessus.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)